in another video we introduced ourselves
to the idea of powers of 10 we saw that
if I were to just say 10 to the first
power that means that we're just really
just going to take 110 if we have 10 to
the second power that means that we're
going to take two tens so a 10 and a 10
and we're going to multiply them and so
that's going to be 100 if we take 10 to
the third power that's going to be three
tens multiplied together which is equal
to 1,000 which is also one followed by
three zero so you're already starting to
see a pattern what we're going to do in
this video is think about patterns when
we multiply arbitrary things or divide
our buri things by powers of 10 so let's
start with a number let's say I will
start with 2.3 and let's first just
multiply it by 10 to the first power
well that's the same thing is just
multiplying it by 10 and we've seen
already when you multiply by 10 you
shift all the digits one place to the
left so the two which is in the ones
place will end up in the tens place and
then three which is in the tenths place
will end up in the ones place so this is
just going to be equal to 23 and it's
always good to do a little bit of a
reality check if I just had two and if I
were to multiply it by 10 you say okay
that's about 20 so it makes sense that
two point three times ten is twenty
three but let's keep going now let's
multiply 2.3 not by ten to the first
power which is just ten but let's
multiply it times ten to the second
power what is that going to be pause
this video and see if you can figure
that out
all right well ten to the second power
we already know that's equal to a
hundred and so when you multiply by a
hundred or you multiply by 10 twice
you're just going to shift every digit
two places to the left so let me draw
some places here so the thing that is in
the ones place will go to the hundreds
place and the thing that is in the
tenths place will go to the tens place
and so this too will now be to hundreds
this 3/10 will now be three tens and we
now have zero ones and then if we were
to multiply by ten again so if we were
to say 2.3 times 10 to the third power
well then we're going to shift
everything three places to the left ten
to the third power this is the same
thing as multiplying by 1,000 so two
point three times ten to the third the
two is going to be shifted three places
to the left so the two is going to
become 2,000 which makes sense so it's
going to be 2000 the 3/10 is going to
shift two places to the left so it's
going to be 300 and then we now have
zero tens and zero ones so the pattern
that you've probably seen is if you
multiply a number times 10 to some power
you are just shifting the digits to the
left by that power and if we divide by a
power of 10 the same thing would happen
but we would now be shifting our digits
places to the right so for example what
is 2.3 divided by divided by 10 to the
first power pause this video and try to
figure that out
well ten to the first power is the same
thing as 10 so when we divide by 10 all
of our digits are just going to shift
one place to the right so this 2 is
going to end up in the tenths place and
the 3 is going to end up in the
hundredths place so this is going to
give us zero point 2 3 2 is now in the
tenths 3 is now in the hundredths but we
could keep going what if we were to say
2 point 3 divided by 10 to the second
power pause this video try to figure out
what that is well in this situation we
are going to shift all the digits two
places to the right and so let me put my
places here so that's the ones tenths
hundredths thousandths and so the thing
that's in the ones place is two
it won't just go to the tents it'll go
to the hundreds place which you don't
quite see here's it's right over there
so the two is going to show up here and
then the three is going to shift two
places to the right and so it's going to
end up there and we have zero ones and
we have zero tenths so you're probably
already seeing the pattern here again
whatever the exponent is if you're
dividing by ten to that power you're
going to shift that power that exponent
that many times you're going to shift
the digit that many places to the right